[Music]
over her her Heavenly protection Lord
hear my prayer let the enemy no Victory
behold you're dripping with
blood face me my child I am the
church I am the church stop get away
from
[Music]
me
[Applause]
you stupid you F this your
with
[Music]
me
you're
M take me you
blackhearted no you
did you notice anything unusual a
in HS what are they you know how I think
we should proceed I should grind me up
some oxycotton and have a little
snort everyone in this town is going
crazy I think it's because of me and
these horns you killed that innocent
girl now the devil has claimed you he
didn't kill her father and now people
are telling me all these things I don't
want to hear I'm so bad I'm bad I'm
pretty enough to be on TV right Sadam
sometimes you can love a person very
much but still know that they aren't
right for you what the are you talking
about you treat me like Saddam I'm
leaving you I'm going up to Earth to
rule
alone no no you can't do that I'm sorry
but I have to be strong Satan please
give me another chance I have to go to
earth oh my God God God is
love I don't love
you I I can't I can't do this I can lay
you out and fill your mouth with your
mother's
feces or we can
talk are you one of them
then are you an
angel I am the first Angel loved once
above all others a perfect
love but like all true
love one day it withered on the
vine I don't believe you you're both
lying
you're lying it didn't die you took it
you're lying you witches you're lying
you're lying you're
lying if that's
true then you must know my mother's
maiden
name what is
it
what is
[Music]
it